próximamente 12 años me encontré con el
instrumento que me cambió la vida el
acordeón
llegadas del continente europeo hacia
las costas colombianas a finales de 1800
primero a puertos como en riohacha la
guajira atraviesa el magdalena la sierra
el valle y llega a manos de los
campesinos y juglares en la costa caribe
se enamoran de su sonido reinterpretan
la técnica y se convierte en el
instrumento más representativo de la
música local
el vallenato un género que tiene tras
influencias directas españa' por la
guitarra en nuestro idioma indígena por
la guacharaca y africana por la caja y
esto del tambor y así lo que hoy
conocemos como el género más importante
en la música folclórica colombiana
pero estas son cosas que uno nunca va a
pensar cuando escucho un vallenato
demasiados detalles no
ahora imagínense que hay detrás de
ustedes
de repente se nos ha olvidado el mundo
por descubrir detrás de cada uno de
nosotros
lo primero que a mí me preguntan y yo
creo que ustedes están preguntando es
por qué el acordeón
y cada año que pasa se convierte en algo
más complicado para mí de responder
porque realmente a veces anhelo volver a
este lugar a ese día a ese momento con
tanta verdad cuando yo escogí al
acordeón como mi compañero un momento
donde yo no sabía qué iba a pasar yo no
sabía que me iba a cambiar la vida yo no
sabía que iba a estar aquí frente a
ustedes
y lo más cercano que puedo llegar a
responder es que yo quería encontrar un
instrumento que me acercará al país
donde nací
así que lo primero que realmente empecé
como a sentir en atracción de él fue
solamente su forma yo creo que es un
instrumento que uno lo ve ya le parece
una pieza de arte me enamora su textura
su sonido
hay algo muy curioso en el que fue
terciario aquí en mi pecho no y eso me
implicó a mí tener que aprender a
respirar con él y ya por último pero no
menos importante me enamoré de su música
de las melodías y de unas letras que
empezaron a transportar ni a lugares que
empezaron a mí a presentarme a personas
que me estaban contando historias y para
que se contextualizó en un poquito con
lo que quiero decir les voy a cantar un
fragmento de una canción del maestro
carlos huertas el cantor de fonseca
alguien me dijo de dónde es usted que
canta tan bonito esa parranda si es tan
amable tú que la otra vez quiero
escuchar de nuevo su guitarra óigame
compa usted no es del valle del
magdalena ni de bolívar pues si miento a
que sus cantares son de una tierra
desconocida y yo le dije si a usted le
inspira saber la tierra de donde soy con
mucho gusto y a mucho honor
yo soy del centro del agua
nací en tibia frente al mar caribe de
donde muy pequeño me llevaron ai en
barranca me bautizaron y en toda la
guajira me hice libre yo vi tocar a
santander martínez a bola ni tú a
francisco al hombre a lo le gritó al
señor me pitre los acordeones de gran
renombre doy una tierra grata y honesta
ya que su historia lleva mi nombre yo
soy aquel cantor de fonseca la patria
hermosa de chema gómez
y ésta es sólo una de este tesoro
musical que tenemos en la música
colombiana pero resulta que con esta
canción acabamos de viajar todo el
caribe
acabamos de recorrerlo acabamos de
conocer personas que seguramente para
carlos huertas fueron importantes y
acabamos de recrear una historia que si
yo me voy yo imagino de pronto estaba en
una parranda carlos huerta se empezó a
cantar y de repente le dijeron oiga se
cantó de donde desde por aquí y él dice
no no no no yo no soy día ni de aquí ni
de allá
yo soy de este lugar
y realmente me pareció muy valioso todo
esto empecé a sentir cosas muy
particulares en mí esto me pasa cuando
yo estaba estudiando corrió en la ciudad
de bucaramanga y empecé a sentir esta
necesidad de tener que ir a estos
lugares saben hay algo muy particular
con esta música y es que hay una capital
del vallenato que es valledupar empecé a
hacer tengo que ir a ese lugar y a lo
largo de mi camino en estos 12 años he
podido bueno estar en valledupar y
recorrer el caribe entero y darme cuenta
que todo esto que había en las canciones
era verdad esos lugares si existen estas
personas también existieron estas
historias fueron realmente vividas y me
pasa esto cuando tengo entre 12 y 16
años una época donde uno crea identidad
y carácter
y el hecho de saber de dónde venía esta
música me hizo a mí preguntarme y de
dónde viene diana
me hizo ni pensar en lo poco que me
conocía al no saber de dónde venía
y lo primero que se me viene a mí es la
palabra identidad
hace poco en estos viajes que los
músicos tenemos tuve dos meses muy
agitados que tuve que recordar muchos
países y ciudades con muchas culturas
con muchas lenguas y opiná tan aturdida
tanta información pero llegué con algo
aquí cuando volvía al país y fue de
cualquier parte del mundo donde diana
pudo haber nacido de cualquier parte del
mundo donde ustedes pudieron haber
nacido nos pusieron acá en colombia
y yo no sé pero a mí eso me dice algo
me di cuenta que yo no soy una hoja
blanco
todos como que venimos con un kit adn
que adn nuestros padres abuelos del
pueblo la ciudad donde nos creamos de la
música de la comida de nuestro carácter
no es de gratis que a mi me gusta el
arepa santanderiana al caldo con huevo
el mute no es de gratis que a mí me
digan que soy mal genial
porque tenemos historias detrás de
nosotros que tenemos que aprender a
valorar y querer porque al fin y al cabo
es lo que somos aprender a querer ese
pasado para estar aquí en este presente
tranquilos y empezar a construir ese
futuro que a la larga es lo que
realmente es de nosotros y terminamos
escogiendo con nuestras propias verdades
y construyendo nuestro camino
pero que tan valientes somos de tomar
ese camino y no ir de pronto detrás de
fulanito de tal o ir a la fija o tomar
la carrera que ya sabemos que nos va a
dar dinero
porque es que a lo largo de nuestras
vidas vamos a tener personas el colegio
la universidad el trabajo donde nos van
a estar imponiendo muchas verdades unas
únicas verdades me pasa a mí cuando
empecé a tocar acordeón me choque con un
género que solamente lo tocaban los
hombres y cuando yo quería me decía no
las mujeres no tocan acordeón usted se
va a ver como un macho usted no tiene la
fuerza instrumento pesa bueno dejes a un
lado voy a tocar acordeón y empecé a
tocar acordeón y medianos pero se tiene
que hacerlo como un hombre de verdad y
tiene que cantar con un hombre como un
hombre si yo como que como un macho y
como un hombre si de pronto yo no quiero
hacerlo así y empecé a buscar mi manera
mi forma de hacerlo resulta que si las
mujeres si tocamos a corrido
cuando empiezo la universidad a estudiar
música
en una academia pese a sentir una idea
que me estaban ahí como tratando de
inculcar y era como la música europea
académica clásica es mejor que la música
folclórica empírica de nuestro folklore
colombiano y yo me puse como esto a mí
no me cabe en la cabeza empezando porque
yo me enamoré de la música por esta
parte de la tradición oral
y porque en qué país estamos parados si
uno se va para yopal y encuentra arpas y
cuatros y saltamos para cal y
encontramos salsa y váyase más al
pacífico y encuentra marimbas y saltemos
hasta córdoba y montería y encontramos
bandas encontramos porros y saltemos a
cartagena champeta bajemos a montes de
maría tenemos tambores y gaitas
valledupar con su vallenato bajemos a
los santanderes con música andina
o sea tremenda riqueza musical que me
van a decir que es mejor que esto no
tiene el mismo valor
y cuando ya quise empezar a aprender mi
camino como cantante con mis canciones
empecé a sentir unas ideas poco fuertes
a través de la industria musical y era
sin disquera no lo puede hacer tiene que
pegar una canción tiene que hacer una
inversión millonaria para que pueda
hacer música y la verdad no no no me
convencía tampoco eso de que solamente
había ese camino y de una u otra manera
empecé a encontrarme con otras formas de
lograr esto y resultó que en febrero de
este año una chica común y corriente con
ganas de hacer música sacó su álbum y
hace un mes la academia más importante
de la música los latin grammy me nominó
como mejor álbum en la categoría
vallenato cumbia
[Música]
y yo no tengo disquera
yo no he pegado una canción
[Música]
y tampoco he hecho una inversión
millonaria para hacer música y hacer lo
que quiero
y esto realmente me puso a pensar que
estas verdades que nos imponen se pueden
destruir pero que nuestras verdades se
deben construir
y para construir se necesita amor y en
el amor tiempo y una palabra mágica que
me acompañado hace unos años y es la
disciplina
con la disciplina yo he tenido que pasar
por encima de nadie yo no he tenido que
demostrarle a nadie nada pero si me
podía encontrar a mí si se podía darme
cuenta de mis virtudes y de mis
falencias he podido convertir falencias
en virtudes también me dado cuenta en lo
que necesito en mi vida y lo que no
necesito y ahí les quiero incluir pérez
as vicios personas
yo sé que estoy en una generación en una
época un poco distraía no tenemos este
elemento de la tecnología que nos da
tantas opciones pero que también nos
distrae un poco saben nos aleja de eso
que somos
de nuestra verdad de nuestro presente
nos aleja de esa parte única que tienes
tú que yo no tengo
nos hemos olvidado de nosotros
escucharnos de sentirnos
de perdonarnos
de descubrirnos
y hoy vengo acompañada de dos mujeres
muy especiales para mí
carolina de laos desde barranquilla
[Aplausos]
tiene ángulo desde cartagena estás
solo una pequeña parte de la familia de
diana burgo
y a través de la música lo que me pasó a
mí fue que me logré encontrar me logré
dar cuenta del tesoro de país que
tenemos a nivel de música y cultura y de
personas realmente pero también me
encontré con que a la música le hace
falta más mujeres estamos muy
acostumbrados a ver escenarios y porque
estas y bandas gigantes llenas de
hombres y con esto no quiero decir que
seamos mejores no pero sí quiero decir
que hace falta
quiero cantarles dos de mis canciones
y contarlos también de dónde vienen esas
canciones porque también tienen su
historia yo quería volver a uno de los
ritmos más bonitos que tenemos es la
cumbia y también volver a estas
canciones que le ponían nombre apellido
cierto con alicia dorada fidelina carmen
gómez ya hoy en día uno le da como susto
es el apellido pero en esta canción lo
que hago es jugar también con la
historia del donjuán
[Música]
qué
estás en mis sueños
dijo elaborar
el placer de tu vas a mirar y vivo
soñando que me
aunque a mí me toque
estás en mis sueños y yo te canto
vivo laboral el placer de tus besos que
da vida y vivo soñando
de enamorado
[Música]
diciéndole a todas quiero pero a mí
bueno
enamorando
que va diciéndole a todas te quiero pero
a mi nombre
pero yo vivo a matar la cabecita parecer
y después marcharse
mi amor para después marcharse y vuelvo
enamorando y diciéndole adelante que la
pero a mí no me dice nada
[Música]
m
al final del día de capacidad porque
tanto año
me da igual
me enamoré de un dolor que va y
siguiéndole a todas te quiero pero a mí
no me hice mal
[Música]
sí sí
no sé de dónde salió
de calidad
l
[Música]
sí
tras las
[Aplausos]
la siguiente canción para terminar y que
sigan todos mis compañeros porque vienen
unas charlas divinas
esta canción que voy a interpretar les
es un vallenato tradicional siempre soñé
con poder lograr volver a esas melodías
que nos transportan a los lugares a las
personas viejo amor del valle habla de
estos amores de pronto que hemos tenido
de de muy pequeños no estos niños que
terminan como en un anhelo permanente
que de pronto uno a veces va y recuerda
y todavía quedan cosas ahí
[Música]
nuevamente
ay
[Música]
con esos ojitos negros que de niña me
engañaron
el hombre no te creas que sí porque si
el mundillo quiste fue un hombre
provinciano
el alma y si te vuelvo a ver voy a
volver a la pasarela
como si nunca te viera porque tu cariño
a mi me alegra pero soy aquella niña que
la pequeña te espera
[Música]
por asume porque tu palabra debilidad y
ahora voy a dejar que me encantó tu peso
bueno a otro grupo y toma verso
[Música]
no hay miembro aporte al valle muy
fuerte a tomar mis terroristas vuelvo a
ser las canciones que ábrete amores que
fueron secretos y son condenas hay dónde
hay viejo amor del vallès hoy vuelvo a
tumbar me da rabia vuelvo a hacer
canciones que hablen cada vez que fuera
un secreto si son banderas
ah
[Música]
y si te vuelvo a ver mi amor pasará de
largo como si nunca
mira porque tu cariño a mi me ha dejar a
una pena soy aquella niña que la pequeña
te espera
bueno
porque tu debilidad
yo no tuve bueno
una versión guardavallas
/ del valle hoy vuelvo a comprar mi
estabilidad y vuelvo a ser canciones que
habría poder y que fueron secretos se
sorprenderán a yo hay un amor del valle
hoy vuelvo a tomarme la carrodilla
vuelvo a hacer canciones que
obligatorias que fueron secretos
exhortan de las acciones a favor del
valle hoy vuelvo a tomar me da rabia
vuelvo a hacer canciones que hablan de
amores que fueron secretos y son
[Música]
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]